[Musique]
1960 c'est la date de naissance du skate
board ce qui veut dire patiner sur une
planche naissance qu'il doit aux
surfeurs de la côte ouest des états unis
et ont trouvé ce judicieux moyens pour
s'occuper les jours où la mère refuse de
faire des vagues
il
faut-il pas
en france le skate fait son entrée pour
la première fois en 1965 arriver
directement des états unis ses premiers
pas sur le sol français ne font pas
grand bruit car le skate n'a pas encore
la forme idéale à l'époque 0 sont en
plastique ce qui veut dire que la
vitesse ainsi que les possibilités de
manoeuvre sont réduits pour celui qui
prend place sur ce petit morceau de bois
[Musique]
en cours
1972 au diable les roues en plastique
remplacé par un produit miracle
l'uréthane qui égale rapidité et tenue
de route
le skate ainsi équipés offre alors un
éventail de possibilités extraordinaires
en forme de liberté
[Musique]
l'origine du skate est à la fois son
principal atout est son plus gros
problème son origine c'est à dire la rue
[Musique]
les skate c'est vraiment formidable
nous apprécions le skate la mer la rue
lépante le bitume cela fait partie de
l'univers du skate son fief le sud ouest
avec un point fort la côte basque
il fait également des adeptes à paris et
c'est à l'angleterre et j'allais tous
les jours faire du patinage à roulettes
quand je sus c'était merveilleux et
j'arrivais à valser je faisais la toupie
alors qu'est ce que vous pensez du des
biens - moi je pense que c'est salir le
roller skating
ça n'a rien à faire à vélo roller
skating c'est un sport à faire arriver
les accidents tous les jeunes
moi ce qui me fait mal au coeur ce corps
de religion avec son accidenté soit par
les voitures bien ou bien leur part dès
la fin il ya pas mal d'accidents
corporels et même l'autre jour il ya eu
un blessé grave fracture du crâne et
même je suis même pas si le policier
delga alors ces jeunes gens n'ont pas de
casque
ils soient protégés enfin ce qu'il
faudrait leur faire ça serait leur créer
une piste qu'ils puissent se dépenser et
oui la rue apparemment ce n'est pas fait
pour cela mais il faut bien s'exprimer
quelque part c'est là tout le problème
[Musique]
pratique dans des stades ça mais c'est
en effet sa voie publique je suis tout à
fait content parce que je vois je suis
une profession
ce pas l'om trottoir où je vois des
vieux qui quelquefois se sont gênés de
voir ces jeunes j'ai dit ces jeunes
parce qu'ils sont sans gêne il faut dire
ce qui est moi j'ai pratiqué le sport
mais j'avais le respect quand même de
toute personne qui était sur la voie
publique
on fait attention mais les gens nous
parlent et si choquant si deux personnes
font attention c'est ok il y en a
certains accents très méchant ça se
manifeste comme en bas ça se manifeste
parfois par des plaintes pour nous
envoient la police à sa sauce manifester
plus violemment aussi il inquiet c'est
l'opposé accident
[Musique]
vous
sai
incontestablement le skate a conquis une
jeunesse peut-être émoussés par le plus
que centenaire patins à roulettes dix à
vingt mille pratique en france 20
millions aux états unis
l'adoc de la rue comme domicile il faut
bien le dire c'est parce que les pistes
de skate sont plutôt rares deux
seulement en europe à londres et à
saint-jean-de-luz et plus qu'insuffisant
heureusement que des projets sont en
cours d'élaboration
un peu partout dans le sud ouest
notamment sport à part entière s'il est
assez facile d'apprendre à faire du
skate détrompez vous faire ça n'est pas
tout simple il faut d'importantes
qualités physiques
d'un coup on pense pas quand on descend
moi beaucoup de choses à court match est
un peu appréhension de la chute quand
même pas peur un petit peu sinon c'est
grisant quand tu na waie c'est
formidable je descends à combien je ne
sais pas ça va faire car la grotte
commettra savent comment tu t'appelles
tu franchement et toi alors quand tu
descends à quoi tu penses à rien rien
ces deux villes c'est le vide c'est ça
qui est bien ce qu est si génial
n'en parlons pas l'entretenir cet aspect
américain non je suis musique
polynésienne s'est pas mué ricains l'une
est française
pantalon un permis qu'alizé mon fois les
tennis française on fait du sport on
n'est pas en me regarde pas qui c'est
mais d'une somme d'une france du moins
qu'on s'amusait pas un problème
[Musique]